let me call your attention back to the
2016 presidential campaign you'll
remember that a very big deal was made
out of Hillary Clinton's emails Hillary
Clinton's email use her private server
it was just evidence of her being the
absolute worst person the most unfit
person to serve as president she's a
criminal we gotta lock her up Donald
Trump even months ago as we learned
thinking about mandating that the
Justice Department prosecute her
something that his own attorney said you
know you could get impeached for that
you may not want to do that so a very
big deal made out of Hillary Clinton's
private email use of course during the
Trump administration we've since learned
that many members of Donald Trump's team
have used private email Jared Kushner
did it very recently we learned about
Ivanka Trump using private email on a
domain owned by Jared Kushner and Yvonne
Ivanka Trump for government-related
business why she's even involved in
government related business is also a
question which is a different question a
former chief of staff Reince Priebus was
using private email there's a very long
list of them step one after that story
broke was to just deny that there's any
similarity between what Ivanka and Jared
and all of the others did and argue that
it was just completely different when
Hillary Clinton did it one of the ways
that they tried to do this was to say
well Hillary Clinton was sending
classified stuff on her private email
server via her private email server
that's not true there were elements of
Hillary Clinton's emails which were
later classified but at the time they
were not and therefore that's just not
true
so that failed miserably saying what
Ivanka did is different than what
Hillary Clinton did so now they've moved
on to step two step two is saying and I
hope you're sitting down for this step
two is saying that government email
standards are just really strict and
awfully tough to actually stick to House
Judiciary Committee Chairman Bob
Goodlatte a I know that's not how they
say it but I like it that way Bob
Goodlatte a Republican from virgin
yeah he was asked about this and he said
you know it's too difficult to comply
with these complicated strict oppressive
rules about email which is of course
absurd I mean check out the mental
gymnastics check out the total
obliteration of logic here all right and
and just quickly before we go since
these emails are of such importance to
you Republican Senator Ron Johnson
obviously on your committee trey Gowdy
and Oversight Committee chairman they
are interested in pursuing Ivanka
Trump's emails to get to the bottom of
exactly what happened there do you
support that well certainly to be
consistent they need to inquire about
what occurred there I have no problem
with that I do think of course it's very
different to send private emails about
matters that are not classified
information there's a criminal penalties
for doing that when you have classified
information that is transmitted
improperly as was the allegation and I
think the facts now support with regard
to Hillary Clinton but certainly when
things like this come up it's important
people understand they need to make sure
that they're doing what they can and
it's awfully tough as everyone knows
when when you're sending emails about a
lot of different things to make sure
that you're doing it according to the
rules in the White House or wherever
you're doing it I'm sure however Clinton
would agree with you all right thank you
very much I appreciate your time
chairman Goodlatte Wow it's just so
tough guys to expect Ivanka to adhere to
those really strict awful rules about
how email is supposed to be used
oh but Hillary Clinton should be locked
up right no the lie mixed in there by
the way I mentioned this before that
Ivanka did an email about classified
matters they're still going with that
and and that hillary clinton was sending
classified stuff no hillary clinton was
emailing things that were later
classified not at the time she sent it
and that's what matters I actually do
think Pat that it's important to keep
hammering Trump on this and not to let
it go not because Ivanka's private email
use is the most
thing but because it so boldly exposes
their hypocrisy on the entire email
issue and because they made it the issue
about Hillary Clinton well if they can
point out significant differences
between Hillary Clinton's use of a
private email and Ivanka Trump's use of
private email then they can kind of get
away with it so some differences that I
can think of is that while Hillary
Clinton was in her 60s Ivanka Trump was
in her 30s at the time of the exchanges
so that's one difference also Hillary
Clinton's a Democrat Ivanka Trump I
think is a Republican so that's
difference number two difference number
three may be that Hillary Clinton's
their reptilian or ran a child sex
pedophile ring at a pizza shop so maybe
we can craft some of these distinct
differences we can kind of get away with
us all yes all right Pat doing material
today but pointing out and I agree with
him that the differences are differences
that aren't really material distinctions
and that this is the same damn thing but
they don't want to hold them to the same
standard and at a certain point if it's
this tough to be in government maybe
they shouldn't be in government and that
gets us to my real issue with this any
time that this issue of Ivanka Trump's
private email use comes up or Jared
Kushner's private email use we must
mention that Donald Trump's daughter
Donald Trump's son-in-law
they shouldn't be working for the White
House in any fashion and this is
ultimately a masterclass in hypocrisy
doesn't matter right now in politics we
could all I hope agree that the United
States would be better off if Ivanka
Trump and Jared Kushner had jobs where
they didn't have to comply with
government email standards because they
weren't working for the government and
as we heard from Democrats in the last
couple of days
this private email use will be the
subject of an investigation once
Democrats are sworn into control of the
House of Representatives in January and
I look forward to that very much one of
the days sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked
directly to your bank account and you
use those virtual credit card numbers to
buy things online which protects your
actual debit card so that it's not
spread all over the internet and one of
the best things about it is how their
mobile app and browser extensions for
Chrome and Firefox make it really easy
to use let's say for example that I'm
signing up for a david pakman show
membership in the credit card number
field I already see the privacy comm
icon I just click it choose which of my
virtual credit cards I want to use and
the credit card number expiration date
and security code are automatically
entered I can put in any zip code I want
and I'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter because
I've already deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy comm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time it is all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time they're giving everyone
in our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link